8 personas están acusadas de ayudar a
mojaven la juez Bullet a llevar a cabo
su ataque con un camión en la ciudad
francesa de Niza son juzgados aquí en el
tribunal penal especial de París la sala
construida originalmente para el juicio
de los atentados terroristas de París de
2015 tres de los acusados eran
presuntamente amigos cercanos del propio
atacante entre ellos se encuentra rams y
arepa un Franco tunecino y el único
acusado que se enfrenta a una posible
cadena perpetua Los otros dos Mohamed
grayff y Chucky chafrut se enfrentará
hasta 20 años de prisión si son
declarados culpables los tres se
enfrentan a cargos de terrorismo y se
les acusa de haber ayudado al atacante
de obtener las armas y el camión que
utilizó para conducir contra la multitud
los otros cinco sospechosos entre los
que uno de ellos será juzgado en
ausencia están acusados de participar en
el tráfico de armas y de intentar
entregar las armas al atacante Aunque
sin saber para qué iban a ser utilizadas
para las víctimas el juicio no es tanto
una venganza sino más bien hacer
entender a los acusa del dolor y el
sufrimiento que han causado se trata de
explicar el sufrimiento que han hecho
pasar a las familias los niños los
padres y los abuelos Espero que
comprendan el dolor que han causado y
que no sientan una especie de placer al
decirse a sí mismos que han triunfado el
juicio durará 10 semanas y se espera un
veredicto A mediados de noviembre